now it did seem that there was a
political consensus around coronavirus
even a few weeks ago but actually just
saw would that last interview it's
starting to crack with more criticism
being made of the government by
opposition parties we can now talk to
you the acting leader of the Liberal
Democrats sir at Davi who joins us now
thank you for being on the program Boris
Johnson returning to work tomorrow you
pleased to see him back absolutely we've
all been wishing well throughout this
him and his family and it will be good
to see him back in Downing Street and
hopefully in charge of this situation
we've got to work together Liberal
Democrats from the start of being
constructive and supportive of the
government experts that teach me the
chief medical officer and be funded
advisor and I'm sure Boris Johnson will
be asking them for advice as soon d gets
back I think that's the point isn't it
there's going to be some really
difficult decisions that the Prime
Minister will need to make in the coming
days and weeks of being back in office
and what plan do you see for loosening
the lockdown we've got to ensure that
the testing the tracing and indeed the
isolation plan is in place people will
need to be tested to see whether they've
got the virus before they could go back
to work and those who test positive
there's got to be a very very
substantial investment in being able to
trace the people that they've been in
contact with in the previous set of days
and then to support people who then have
to go into isolation and indeed people
who are very vulnerable and you'll have
to stay in isolation and not leave their
homes the quite a complicated package
and Liberal Democrats are concerned that
we're way behind on testing and we're
not investing enough in their tracing
that we can really have a proper
community lead testing tracing and
isolation strategy it's interesting to
hear about the emphasis on tracing on
contact tracing effectively tracking
down people who may have been in contact
with an infectious person now in South
Korea that's been some pretty rigorous
controls it's been looking at people's
credit card transactions even CCTV it
could mean tracking people's movements I
mean the Liberal Democrats are
traditionally the party of civil
liberties do you have any con
turns about this kind of unprecedented
surveillance of course we do we've got
to get the balance right but actually in
South Korean Germany they've been
recruiting and training lots of
individual people to do the tracing so
it's not just been central government by
any stretch imagination it's been at the
local level of community level and it's
been human to human that's actually
beating the core of their strategy there
may well be an ability to use some
technology to support that effort but
unless you've got the people in place
unless you're doing it at the community
level
I don't think trading can be effective
so we will need to see if technology can
assist but I don't think we need to put
huge powers in the hands of central
state I think we can adopt an approach
which actually other countries adopting
- I believe go back to Davy who we had
those technical issues with areas warned
the challenges of broadcasting in these
facially distance towns normally you be
here in the studio opposite me but when
you're back now so thank you for
sticking with us and the question that I
asked just before we got cut off was
about whether or not companies
registered in tax havens should be
eligible for government support no they
shouldn't we've seen Denmark opponent
France day that the government support
their giving to businesses should not be
going to you those businesses who you're
not sure now if they come back onshore
and start paying their taxes like all
the other businesses the businesses who
do pay their taxes and of course they'd
be eligible for that support let's
remember we've got to get the money
through the frontline workers the NHS
workers the care workers we've all seen
how fully paid some of the care workers
are and if we're going to actually build
a fairer society out of this so we get
the money do those people who need it in
our public services as Liberal Democrats
believe a much more progressive
approaching we've seen in recent years
then we can't have these companies going
offshore not paying their taxes and
getting taxpayer support that we totally
wrong you mentioned there about the pay
for people like care workers do you
think that those in public services NHS
workers those in care homes should be
given a pay rise as well
well I certainly think so and we live
Democrats have argued that if you look
at what they our soldiers get on the
front line when they're in inaction and
risking their lives they get an
operational allowance every day and I
think the fact that our care workers our
health workers are risking their lives
yes that maybe they should get something
like that and we've been arguing for a
support package but NH NHS workers in
care workers obviously top variety more
protective equipment and help for them
in doing their job at the moment but
also do think they should get a better
debt and service package for example and
certainly some sort of acknowledgement
on pay and longer term I mean I I do
agree with kiss stammer on this I mean
we we're gonna have a progressive
society in a fairer society we've got to
start treating care workers and people
like that frontline workers are better
than we've been doing now something else
that you've been calling for is a public
inquiry into the government's handling
of the pandemic now some people might
hear that and think hang on a minute we
are in the middle of perhaps the biggest
crisis since the world wars are you just
playing politics by calling for
something that will happen in the future
no no when I asked unlike Rob this at
the first virtual p.m. news
I was surprised that he refused to
commit I thought it was going to be very
easy question for him because it would
be absurd if we didn't have an a
independent public inquiry school into
this though he can learn the lessons so
he can get to the truth and so we can
see why we appear to have handle this
less well than other countries and you
know we've had inquiries in other issues
over the years I mean the most obvious
one was back in 2005 when there was an
outbreak of e.coli and staff AIDS in
South Wales Hugh Pennington the
president Pennington had that inquiry
we've had inquiries into the Iraq war
with the Chilcott inquiry and so on it
would be completely wrong not to have an
inquiry let's remember that lots of
people want to ask many questions and
they're not getting answered at the
moment you know why have the care sector
being treated all as a second-class
though the care workers haven't had that
protective equipment and haven't been
even tested and when you're seeing the
appalling death great with with over
20,000 dying in our ask
an Afghan artists of openness because
yesterday yes if you add in those dying
in hospices and the community and
handing care homes we could be looking
at over 40,000 deaths already this is a
national calamity and that's why I just
want the government to pre-commit know
how it will stay that after this is all
over there will be an inquiry and that's
quite an easy question who dance okay
and just finally and Labor's got a new
leader
okay stoma the opportunity to create
fresh team around him elected with a big
new mandate in contrast the Lib Dems
have suspended their leadership contest
until 2021 do you feel that the Lib Dems
are struggling for relevance of the
minute well personal congratulate yes
Dharma I mean he had a very good first
being refused and the Liberal Democrats
are gonna be back we're going to do
develop our vision again we're going to
learn the lessons from what was
disappointing general election but we
have put the national interest first we
cancel a spring conference one of our
major annual political platforms and
we've said from the start that we want
to be supportive of the government and
fiest the expert advice and we've been
me doing that for the national interest
first I don't think this is a time for
the party politic but you know when when
this is all over you know we will be
getting a very clear strong message or
everything from climate change to
improvements in the care sector if
you're learning awful lot and also far
better society I think people have been
surprised the inequalities that have
been being shown through this crisis
them I hope we can therefore build build
on that and actually really have a much
better outcome as a result of this
crisis both tackling the problems
Pacific to the crisis but building a
much better much greener society
afterward I